اهلا بكم من جديد البحار والمحيطات من اهم
ميادين الحروب والتوترات العالميه الحاليه
سواء في اوروبا او حتى في منطقه المحيطين
الهنديه والهدايا كل هذه الامور كشفت عن
اهميه المنظمات البحريه التي تمكن الجيوش
من فرض سيطرتها على هذه المساحات الشسعه
[تصفيق]
شركه القيد مارتن الامريكيه واحده من اهم
الشركات في العالم التي تقدم حلول دفاعيه
بحريه تسعى الكثير من الجيوش حول العالم
للحصول عليها للوقوف على احدث المنظمات
البحريه التي تقدمها الشركه معنا السيد
كريسماستر مدير برامج السفن السطحيه ودمج
الانظمه والاختبارات في الشركه اولا مصر
كريس اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا فيما
يتعلق بسفن وفرقات الهجوم السريعه التي
تستطيع التعامل مع التهديدات على السواحل
لديكم فيلوكيد مارتن منظومات ال سي اس
وسفن القتال السطحيه البحري اولا ما مدى
فعاليه هذه السفن امام التهديدات الساحليه
بشكل عام
شكرا لك على الاستضافه وعلى هذا السؤال
الرائع النموذج السفينه المستخدمه في
البحريه الامريكيه تم تصميمه تحديدا للعمل
في المناطق الساحليه ذات المياه الضحيه
وهو ما لم تستطيع السفن التقليديه والقيام
به الس تو ام ام سي تعد نموذج معززا يتوفر
على قدرات اكبر وهو يتركز على نموذج
السفينه ال سي اس السفينه ام ام سي تتميز
بالمرونه وقدراتها الناريه الكبيره فضلا
عن قدرتها على العمل في المناطق الساحليه
وهي تعد السفينه المثاليه للعمل في مياه
الخليج العربي وبحر العرب والبحر الاحمر
وكل ما يحيط بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه من
بحار
مصر الان هناك تهديد كبير فيما يتعلق
بتهديدات صواريخ روز او حتى تهديدات
الطائرات المسيره انتم فيلوك هيد مارتن
فيما يتعلق بالمنظومات البحريه بشكل عام
كيف تتعاملون مع هذا الامر وما الحلول
الدفاعيه التي تقدمونها تستطيع التعامل مع
هذه التهديدات
تتطور دائما ومن تقدمه شركه لوك هيد مارتن
متمثله في السفينه ام ام سي هو من اعظم
القدرات التي روح الشركه هذه السفينه
لديها نظام واطلاق الصواريخ العمودي مارك
41 وهو الافضل من نوعه في العالم حيث يمكن
مواهمته مع انواع الصواريخ والمهام
المختلفه وسيتم تزويد السفينه ام ام سي
تحديدا بنظام ام بي دي اي للدفاع الجوي
وهو نظام يتميز بقدرات عاليه لاعتراض
الصواريخ الجواله والمسيرات وانواعا اخرى
من الطائرات التي قد تمثل تهديدا للخليج
العربي هذه السفينه هي ملائمه تماما لما
صممت من اجله وهي سوف تكون قادره على
وتتحلى بالمرونه اللازمه لاي تحسينات
المستقبليه اذا دعت الحاجه لها حسب تطور
التهديدات همم مصر كريس السعوديه يعني
لديها تعاقد مع الاكيد مارتن بشان بناء
اربع سفن ال سي اس اولا اين وصل هذا
البرنامج وعلى الجانب الاخر ما هي القيمه
المضافه التي تشكلها هذه السفن بالنسبه
للبحريه السعوديه
يا السوداء
نعم كما اشرت العقد يخص اربعه سفن حيث
تتعاون شركتنا مع البحريه الامريكيه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه لانتاج هذه
السفن ويتم حاليا بناء هذه السفن الاربعه
في حوض بناء السفن التابع لشركه في
ماريلاند بولايه اوسكو‬» السفينه بلغت
المرحله النهائيه من التصنيع وتصحيح
الاخطاء المحتمله في النموذج على اليابسه
بالسفينه ام ام سي قيمه اقتصاديه هائله
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وشركه لوك هيد
مارتن بالاشتراك مع البحريه الامريكيه
والمملكه سوف توفر قدرات كبيره للمملكه في
مجال صيانه السفن واصلاحها واجراء مراجعه
شامله لها وهو ما سوف يسمح للمملكه
بالتكافل بجميع متطلبات صيانه السفن
الاربعه وتحسينها واستخدامها المستخدام
طيله فتره وجودها في الخدمه داخل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من خلال شركات سعوديه
وخبراء السعوديه ونرى ان هذا ينسجم تماما
مع رؤيه 2030 عبر توفر قدرات كهذه في
المملكه ذاته مستر كريست طبيعه التهديدات
التي تواجهها منطقه الشرق الاوسط هذه
المنطقه التي تضم الكثير من الممرات
البحريه التي تؤثر على حركه التجاره حول
العالم ما هي طبيعه الحلول الدفاعيه التي
تقدمها لبيد مارتن تستطيع التعاطي مع هذه
التهديدات
السفينه المثاليه للتعامل مع كل التهديدات
فقد ارسلت ثلاث مرات الى الخليج العربي
علمتني سفن حربيه وفرقاطات اكبر عندما كنت
اعمل في البحريه الامريكيه تلك كانت سوفا
كبيره لا تناسب مياه الخليج العربي عكس
السفينه ام ام سي لما يتوفر على متنها من
اسلحه وقدره قتاليه ما يجعلها السفينه
الاكثر في الخليج العربي على ضمان امن
الملاحه بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وكذلك لتامين خطوط التجاره الدوليه في
الخليج العربي مساره كريس منستر مدير
برامج السفن السطحيه ودمج الانظمه
والاختبارات في شركه الوكيد مارتن
الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
التوضيحات